what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alva here I'm running so late I am
getting ready to go on a road trip I'm
gonna have the video but later tonight
right before I leave and I'm there's
going to be like a little announcement
in there I'm hoping you guys can watch
it because gonna need you guys's help
for something while I'm gone I haven't
even started packing yet I'm supposed to
leave in a couple hours but I saw this
honest trailer drop regarding to the
galaxy 2 I was like well I'm gonna be
late because I have to watch this before
I go and I wanted to share this tweet
that we got from Andy signor I'm really
okay we can do this Andy I just want to
cuddle up in that bearskin belly of
yours and oh my god you're so sexy
I like the lumberjack look I hope that
we can still go on the honest trailers
commentary I hope that didn't deter you
okay let's watch this
Yuriko from Marvel and James guy the
director in studio surprised everyone
with guardians of the galaxy comes a
cloaking super fun laugh out loud but
ultimately kind of forgettable sequel
yeah and all the other Marvel cartoons
except for winter so yeah is that better
going they are now August fall you to
blast off again with Marvel's face of
injuries a team of misfits who learned
how to work together in their first
movie then turn back in a like a
professional eyes oh it is playable
action comedy where the heroes never
really get hurt
no the danger never really feels that
imminent no and the jokes definitely
don't go black but let's be honest they
aren't as funny as the characters think
they are okay Wow I don't realize how
much life is in this movie so do you
know whoa laughter just keeps going like
a little hey let me decide when to laugh
all right just shut up no much of it I
didn't realize with all your favorite
heroes black star-lord
he discovers he's the son of a god and a
[ __ ]
well I don't know what you're talking
about that is good or did you the stroke
silent that escrows to become a strong
silent badass with the more interesting
sister and add remaining toys hands eyes
don't work apparently and using my left
I'm using my wrong idea alright that's
how eyesight works you see the
brightness it's added there's something
newcomer Mendez with the power of
getting roasted by everyone
girl should be able to do it with this
we could skinnier she appears to be
completely including ourselves I'm
certainly grateful to defenses and raha
the wants tragic warrior whose they come
that aggressively does sex rate would
you make a penis fire would tell the
story of impregnating my mother have
since there's no it would be and their
regions look you have a good thing going
with Drax don't take it too far in earth
or your best character prepare for an
episode is your goods any stage in a
film that's so high on frame I'm your
real family you'll swear you're watching
The Fast and Furious movie I finally
found my family and thought you ready
Act you're right
this family contrast family is ego those
are relevant matter of exposition I
college the expansion it is my purpose
now it is yours as he groups
everything's better with Kurt Russell
making ego the Living Planet grounded
and relatable until he goes for moral
Billa and becomes a blue alien made of
sky and the universe based that to
proves that everything is better with
Michael Rooker and John do is read
common to a good guy who just learned to
be a good Pappy all to create maximum
emotional impact when he's cooled off in
the most tragic marvel death since he
came back he came back and came back he
came back twice he came back on TV with
silver I guess it's the only buddy boy
Robert y'all so get ready for a great
time at the Tea Room as they bring back
everything you love about the first
movie the music the slow-mo walks and
the insane visuals to the things you
didn't think you'd come back like a
laughing at the dumb name [ __ ] Starling
even it pays at night welcome having
some boring
we're just kidding about the leg guys
are gonna be party weather money and
undercutting most of the serious
traumatic moments with jokes even the
emotional climax of the bill I tried so
hard to find the forum as soon as you
it's ok bar well we've been following
these movies for 10 years out you can
let us go without a chuckle Virginia
didn't be the father I've always wanted
to be excuse me
gonna take a whiz maybe not story or 30
on Bravo Reena warrior princess big blue
billboard drag shepherd
I am merge Romero hot whistle at you
murk Magister baggage ego the [ __ ]
planet and ready player one yeah dad
rock the movie haha let's pull a zoom
whatever what is listening to on earth
nowadays
Oh the Sooners from the early 2000s I
don't think Star Wars gonna be adding
any fines that would happen to rock and
roll
cut my life into pieces this is my last
word on topic I shine pickle rig-i a
Mary Poppins ooh I'm a fluffy kitten
with my sassy macrame mittens the Tobey
Mercurio edge in spider-man 3 was kinda
haha I just paid a Jay oh wow okay
well John and I did a non-spoilery
review that was like 20 minutes long and
then a spoiler review that was like
double the length so I've talked plenty
about guardians of the galaxy vol 2 I
haven't rewatched it since I saw it into
theaters I mean all things talked about
the reviews are definitely present here
the way a lot of the jokes were handled
the way to racks his character was
handled how ego is an interesting
character and then he turns into it like
a rather typical Marvel villain and I
feel like when people saw a review
because we had a lot of criticism
towards it it's easy for that to be the
only thing that's hurt when in reality
Joe and I like in the movie we enjoyed
it we thought it was good but it didn't
make us go I got a rewatching the
theatres or now that it's out on blu-ray
we got to go get it but I'm sure down
the road I'm going to watch it again
a couple of things I like they pointed
out here with yondu's death and this is
the most impactful death in the Marvel
series you know they were pointing out
like all these people die but they all
come back to life and how quick soldiers
death was one of the more emotional ones
but it was only an age of Ultron there's
already a crapload of characters in that
movie and I already appreciated the hell
out of yon to his death but watching
this honest trailer actually made me
appreciate it a lot more I'm hoping that
he does stay dead because yondu became
like everyone's favorite character at a
guardians of the galaxy too but the
impact of his death would be diminished
if they just gave fanservice and had him
come back to life because a part of me
is like yeah I want your honor to come
back the other part of me like nah he
should say dead the amount of time the
character is laughing this movie I did
not pick up on I picked up on the jokes
not being as strong but the amount of
laughter like that they kept cutting
around that was going on for a while in
this on his trailer like holy crap a lot
of these characters especially Drax just
wouldn't stop laughing
and while that might be a more of a
nitpick thing and I didn't necessarily
get annoyed by that when I was watching
the movie
in retrospect what should not disturb
him like that is kind of annoying now
that I think about it the only thing I
don't really agree with in this honest
trailers are talking about how matches
is kind of like a punching bag of the
jokes from all the characters that they
said someone like that but really it was
just Drax who was constantly bag on her
the whole time she bags on herself a
little bit but even the clips they used
was primarily just Drax making fun of
her even though I don't think this film
is on par with the first one or I would
even call it like a really great film I
still think it's pretty good and I
wouldn't call it forgettable I still
really remember my experience and how a
lot of the film plays out and I don't
feel like I'm gonna end up forgetting
how it goes down and I don't know if
it's because how it should have ended
already pointed it out but I remember in
the how it should have ended video they
pointed out how ego and Darth Vader is
kind of similar to the relationship they
have you know with star-lord Luke
Skywalker there are similarities there
that I didn't notice until his II
pointed it out and I thought honest
trailers might do it but maybe how it
should have ended already death is that
there really was a fantastic on its
trailer and then really I kind of want
to watch going into the galaxy vol 2
again not
on it but I feel like a film like
guardians of the galaxy - I would get
more from there from a repeat experience
anyway guys good - think of the honest
trailer you should subscribe to screen
junkies subscribe to the real rejects
I'm Greg Alba I got to get ready to go
out of town haven't even started packing
yet